i flew down to mexico to spend seven
days straight in complete darkness and
isolation in a room that was built to
let absolutely no light in
all right here we go i don't know if i'm
ready for this
whoa no and i did this for reasons you
probably wouldn't expect
but first i had to get familiar with
living in the dark i don't know where
the toilet is
to just sit down and hop for the best
perfect landing unfortunately you
couldn't put toilet paper into the
toilet so
nope so initially i thought i would have
pretty good spatial awareness
but it is so bad all i had was a basic
room with a bed
a meditation chair and a bathroom no
entertainment just me
and my thoughts food would be delivered
twice a day into this
box with a two-door mechanism so even
then no light would come in
it's so weird i can't see anything it
takes a certain level of trust
to just be like okay i'm gonna put this
thing that sounds a bit slimy in my
mouth
i have no idea what that is what i'm
eating right now sometimes i lose my
camera
i'm sorry but why did i sign up for this
i've done virtually every psychedelic
drug it was
um i think by far the most powerful
medicine journey i've ever been on
in the dark room you producing melatonin
and phi emo and dmt after only a few
days in the dark your brain would
naturally produce dmt
an insanely powerful hallucinogenic drug
that can feel like a near-death
experience
and you see lies see colors seriously i
see past
life so me and my friends chris and
aaron decided we just had to do it and
they were in the buildings next to me do
you feel ready for the
darkroom did a final brain scan you took
your brain scan machine with you okay
yeah
we took a brain scan before and after
the experience to see how it would
affect our minds and the results were
absolutely stunning but as you'll see we
had no idea
what we were getting ourselves into i'm
gonna go sit down and meditate for a bit
i feel very uneasy i'm quite nervous
actually i have to admit i am scared
i feel like no matter how hard i tried
my mind is just so
active completely out of control right
now it might only be
seven or eight pm but i think i'm gonna
try to sleep now
it's day two i have no idea what time it
is
now last night i did see what looked
like
a moonlight and before there were
shadows i think it might be 24 hours now
that i've been in here
it's gonna be so long not drinking or
eating anything for three days was hard
and
injecting myself frog poison but hoping
this is definitely the hardest thing
i've done
this far the most unsettling thing i
read was that
the hallucinations in darkness retreats
are not just fun and games
a lot of it is demonic creatures that
are lurking in the dark and even
characters from horror movies that could
jump out at you
i'm starting to have very blurry black
and white visuals of just
different patterns that i'm seeing
almost like in a dream where you see
certain things that don't make any sense
now i'm going to edit something in that
looks a little bit like it like a horse
with
three legs wearing a hat
what like right now i'm picturing
different layers of the earth there's
different rocks in there and there's
kind of like fluffy stuff in between
at the top there's a moon that looks a
little bit like an eye as well it has
really bushy eyebrows and then it
moves into something else my editing is
not good enough for this please just
imagine it i was seeing some weird stuff
it was hard to
[Music]
but describe knows maybe i'm right on
schedule for
going crazy well there was definitely
some truth to that and it was just
it was just torture
it's day four i don't know what to tell
you just
keep thinking about these these
insecurities that i have
i just can't stop thinking about it it
just keeps coming back and it's just
this
the best way i could describe it is
imagine your
darkest fears and deepest insecurities
playing like a movie in your mind over
and over and over again
and the harder you try to look away the
longer it's going to play
so there's no escape i feel in my chest
it is literally physically painful i
just want this to be over
seriously and that continued for the
next few days
no distractions no escape but eventually
it
made sense why i was going through this
when we got the results from our brain
scans
after the doctor treatment when your
brain is calm there's
zero emotional recall so liam when i see
stuff like this it makes me think of a
ptsd
pattern my guess is you went through
some stuff in that room
as weird as it sounds it seems like i
needed this
i literally have everything i need to be
fully happy
my cup is not just full it's overflowing
and i just don't see it what a waste to
not
be completely happy every day
we're privileged to be alive we think
we're owned something by the world
or by life that we deserve something but
we already have everything
we owe something we're already in debt
but still the last couple days were
probably the most challenging
man i just want to get out of here i
literally just
want to get out of here because the
light visuals that i had over the last
few days have been increasing
i was getting ready for the most
challenging part the dmt release which
usually happens between day
five to seven i've had more flashing
lights
quite intensely they have a little more
color to them it looks like there's
thousands of
tiny bats flying around i kept
meditating i kept waiting i kept just
hanging in there but it just wouldn't
happen and maybe it's good that it
didn't happen because it did for my
buddy chris and
he said i don't know if i could have
handled that the crying was so intense
snot is running down my face like tears
like i can't control it
there's no words for this but i think
buddhist like explained this as a state
of nirvana i felt this
inner light core in me and it just
radiated i felt like it was my soul
and then like the intense
hallucinations came in it was
uncontrollable then
see these grids see these lights
it was just like seeing another realm it
was so intense
that i thought if this doesn't go away
i'm gonna have to leave the dark room
and thankfully i woke up the next
morning and
i was a reset and when the final day
arrived
it's the final morning i made it i'm
just waiting for the signal
that it's 5am coming out of that room
and seeing light again
was just surreal hello
is it tuesday i can't remember a time
where i felt
more joy and excitement i was like a
little child
oh this is bright
i'm back
[Music]
let's open the door and the brain scan
results were just
incredible your dark room session
totally healed
the brain we might have to write this up
as a paper or do
something to let the world know about
how you guys
changed your brain is that aaron that i
see there's chris
we went to see the sunrise and it was
just so beautiful
and even though it was incredibly
challenging we did it
i learned so much in these seven days in
the end it's all about people
meaningful relationships friends family
loved ones it's all about that